She's not a bird or a plane, and she's definitely
not Superman!
Melissa Benoist is CW’s Supergirl, but how
did she get ready for the part?
Let’s take a look at how this self-proclaimed
musical theater nerd got into fighting condition
to play the high flying, hard punching Supergirl.
You don't just get handed a role like Supergirl.
Melissa Benoist had to go through a rigorous
audition process before she got anywhere close
to landing the role.
The wait was made even more excruciating because,
according to Benoist, she was the among the
first actors to audition for the part.
That first audition was in October 2014, and
it was just the start of what would become
a months-long process.
She told Entertainment Weekly that she didn't
learn she landed the part until February 2015.
In the interim, she said,
"I went through multiple screen-tests, multiple
auditions with the producing team.
There was a lot."
During that extensive audition process, Variety
reported that Benoist found a champion in
producer Greg Berlanti.
Benoist said,
"Greg championed me the whole time and was
in my corner.
Even when I didn't think the part was mine,
he was always rooting for me.
That support goes a long way, especially when
I'm fighting for something I want so badly.
His belief in me really touched me."
Berlanti echoed the sentiment, praising the
Supergirl star by saying,
"If we had not found her, I would have said,
'I don't want to make this.'"
The first episode aired almost a year after
that first audition, on October 26, 2015.
She's inhabited the role ever since, serving
as an inspiration for fans around the world.
"Are there like a million little girls who
dress up as Supergirl now, as a result of
the show?"
"Every Halloween there are quite a bit of
Supergirls."
One thing that all superheroes have in common
are incredible abs, and Benoist's Supergirl
is no exception.
She has said in interviews that to prepare
for the role of Kara Zor-El , she focused
on both strength training and core work, getting
toned with a combination of Pilates, boxing,
and plyometrics.
If you've never had a reason to get into superhero
shape, you might be wondering what plyometrics
are.
Plyometrics involve exerting your body to
its maximum ability for a short period of
time for example, by jumping to improve strength,
speed, and power.
As Benoist found out, plyo routines are far
from easy work.
"I did quite a bit of training.
We did this stuff called plyometrics, which
is like jump training.
And all of it was really hard — just hard
things!"
All that focus on the core isn't just for
the sake of looking good.
It also comes in handy when you're doing flying
stunts.
"I'm up on a wire, and you have to hold your
entire body weight so there's a lot of training
involved."
Melissa Benoist wasn't the only cast member
who had to up her workout intensity to give
the action sequences the effort they deserved.
Chyler Leigh, who plays Kara's adoptive sister
Alex, said that the actors work really hard
with the stunt coordinators to get the fight
scenes just right.
And those action-packed days are full-on workouts
in their own right.
She told CBS' Watch!
Magazine,
"When we do fight scenes, we're working out
for six hours, just doing the same thing.
We are burnt for the next few days.
I think that's really where I get my caloric
burn count."
Even when they aren't shooting, Leigh and
Benoist try to use those periods of waiting
around that happen on the set of a TV show
to stay in shape.
She said,
"Melissa and I try to do as much as we possibly
can.
In my trailer, I've got resistance bands and
medicine balls and things like that.
I try to do it in between, but we have very
little downtime."
The two on-screen sisters also have a shared
interest in pilates, which Leigh says she
fits into her schedule when she can.
And you thought TV sets were all hanging out
in trailers, enjoying craft services.
"YES!"
Another crucial element of being a superhero
is being able to convincingly kick some villainous
butt.
This didn't come naturally to Benoist, who
confessed to the Chicago Tribune,
"I had never punched anyone!
I maybe slapped my sisters when I was a kid,
but I'm not an aggressive, violent person,
and I had no idea how to throw a punch."
In order to help herself find her inner fighter,
Benoist took up boxing.
She told InStyle,
"I definitely had to learn technique.
Like how to actually punch someone and not
hurt yourself more than you're hurting the
person you're punching."
Fortunately for Benoist, she had access to
excellent tutors.
In addition to the stunt team, former karate
and kickboxing world champion Lexi Alexander
directed an episode in the first season.
Her directing stint was short, but Alexander
told Den of Geek that she pushed her star
to the limit, saying:
"This was a brand new thing for everybody
involved, and everybody was excited that a
real fighter was getting Melissa [Benoist]
to the next level of fight choreography."
In fact, the change in Benoist's technique
was so dramatic that Alexander said the series'
stunt team changed Benoist's fighting style
going forward to incorporate her expert tips.
So while Benoist might at heart still be more
a lover than a fighter, we still wouldn't
want to challenge her to throw down at this
point.
"I actually kind of love it.“
Believe it or not, it really is Benoist doing
some of those hair-raising stunts on the show.
The actress told Variety that she likes to
get involved with the action when she can,
saying,
"I have been doing a lot [of stunts], and
I want to keep doing them.
[...] Supergirl's fight moves are boxing.
She's really heavy-handed.
There's some flying that involves kicking
and punching mid-flight that's kind of awesome."
However, not everyone was thrilled with Benoist's
hands-on approach to fights.
Her mom, Julie, told her that she found it
difficult to watch her daughter's fight scenes,
especially against men.
But Julie Benoist needn't have worried.
Melissa knows her limits, and she's also heaped
praise on her stunt doubles.
In 2015, she spoke to InStyle on the subject
of stunts, saying,
"I think they're so fun.
There are some that I just can't I really
could get injured."
"You should rest some more."
"Since when has that ever worked with me?
Heheh."
Glee was not Benoist's first experience with
musical theater.
She says she's been practicing the craft since
she was four years old, attending classes
in tap, ballet, and jazz dance.
But she wasn't always a perfect student, especially
in ballet.
"All the years I took ballet class [teeny
splice here] I was the one kid in class who
the teacher was always like, 'Urgh, her turn-out,'
and, 'She is not standing up straight.'"
She did better with another form of dance,
which she showed off in a video for Glamour.
"I have a secret superpower — that I can
tap dance."
That dance training comes in handy on the
set of Supergirl and not just for Benoist's
part in the musical crossover episode of The
Flash.
"I have to say, I'm not impressed / By your
more famous cousin."
"Thank you!
No one ever says that."
Benoist said that her dance background helps
her with the wire work and even the fight
sequences.
She told the Chicago Tribune,
"The wire work and flying, even the choreography
[...] kind of came like it would if I were
learning a dance routine."
It's also a handy skill that keeps her and
the crew entertained between takes.
Melissa Benoist's favorite thing about her
superhero role is exactly what you'd expect:
the chance to fly.
"It seems like flying wouldn't be so great
when you're pretending to fly."
"I mean, I get to fly!
I mean it's hard work, I'm essentially attached
to a fork in the air."
Despite how some skilled animators make it
look on screen, flying isn't easy, especially
when you have to act like it's all effortless
to you.
Benoist told Variety just how hard it was
and how she prepared, saying,
"The wire work for training is mostly core
work.
It's mostly ab-centric — the whole area
of the body that nobody wants to work out.
You have to get strong.
You have to carry your whole body weight when
you're up in the air."
However, it's worth all the working out to
make the process run smoothly.
She told People,
"The wire work is really difficult, but so
fun.
And when you get it right, watching the result
is exhilarating.
It's a really, really cool feeling to know
what it felt like, the energy I had to exert
to create those flying scenes.
And then the way they look is really rewarding."
Benoist got some help perfecting her flying
technique.
When Jimmy Kimmel asked how she figured out
Supergirl's flying style, she had a surprising
answer in store.
"There's this sort of superhero physicality
school that you kind of have to go to
where the
stunt team will teach you to walk like a superhero…"
And that's how to look fly in spandex.
All of that working out and on-set action
builds up an appetite.
But as a female superhero who's expected to
squeeze into a tight superhero suit every
day, and have the muscles to beat up bad guys
without actually looking all that bulked up,
Benoist can't exactly go to town on craft
services.
Fortunately, she's pretty into fruits and
vegetables anyway.
She gushed to Glamour,
"I love supermarkets, I love grocery shopping,
I love the produce aisle, because to be super
you have to be healthy.
And I would probably stock up on all the fruits.
However, she isn't about to totally deprive
herself of comfort foods.
In the same Glamour interview, she said,
"If I could supersize any food it would be
[an] ice cream Drumstick, vanilla caramel.
They're so good."
In 2016, she told the Chicago Tribune that
she was excited to attend that year's Chicago
Comic-Con and Entertainment Expo, aka C2E2,
not just to commune with fellow artists and
fans, but because she wanted to check out
the city's restaurants.
As she explained, quote, "I've heard the food
scene is incredible, and I'm a foodie, so
I can't wait to go out and eat."
Benoist also said that her own partiality
to the occasional junk food splurge inspired
the writers to add the habit into her character's
personality.
She said,
"I love junk food, I love doughnuts, and they
put that in there quite a bit."
Do you like donuts?"
"Who doesn't like donuts."
"I know a place."
It just goes to show that as long as you're
disciplined with your workouts, you don't
have to deprive yourself of every treat you
love.
One reason Melissa Benoist was so invested
in making sure her character could be physically
impressive on screen was because she wanted
to inspire other women to feel strong and
powerful in their own lives.
In an essay for Time, she wrote,
"I think the more the show goes on, the more
you see this fierceness and what women are
really capable of.
It puts [Supergirl] on this equal playing
field.
[…] That's so meaningful to me to help children
understand that girls can have just as much
fun as their male counterparts in the superhero
world.
It's about confidence and hope, and Supergirl
really embodies all of that."
Even though Benoist also wrote that she grew
up in a, quote, "really strong, feminine family,"
she told the Chicago Tribune,
"I didn't really believe that I could be that
character or play a superhero.
It's something I never thought of myself as
doing, but I just knew I had to go for it
because there's so few female superheroes
and just strong females that fight back and
do it with grace and do it with love."
She's also said that she didn't want the character
to be a female version of male superheroes,
saying,
"What I think is cool is to try to bring kind
of a femininity to her strength.
[…] I do like the idea of bringing in like
a grace to it.
And a fluidity and kind of this femininity
to flying.
It's fun."
In other words, Melissa Benoist is out here
bringing new meaning to (Super) girl power.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.